Call me old-fashioned, but I still believe that before we go to war with any country, we have to agree as a nation on how to pronounce its name: I-rack E-rack, Irock, Errack. Let's get it together people. Have you heard this story? Back in July, a Democratic senator on the Senate Intelligence Committee asked the nation's intelligence agencies for a report explaining just how much of a threat Saddam Hussein was.
请原谅我老派，但我依然认为，在我们对任何国家发动战争之前，我们作为一个国家必须就如何念那个国家的名字达成一致：I-rack（伊拉克）、E-rack（伊拉克）、Irock（伊拉克）、Errack（伊拉克）。各位，让我们统一起来好吗？你们听过这个故事吗？早在七月，参议院情报委员会的一位民主党参议员要求国家情报机构提交一份报告，解释萨达姆·侯赛因究竟构成了多大的威胁。
There are 13 different intelligence agencies in our country. And they were saying different things. So Senator Bob Graham from Florida asked for a report, which would look at all the data from all the agencies and come to one set of conclusions. If the Senate was going to have to vote on a war, it seemed important to have a clear sense of just how much danger Iraq posed or did not pose.
我国有13个不同的情报机构，而他们的说法各不相同。因此，来自佛罗里达州的参议员鲍勃·格雷厄姆要求一份报告，汇总所有机构的数据，并得出一个结论。如果参议院必须对一场战争进行投票，那么清楚地了解伊拉克究竟造成了多大程度的危险似乎是很重要的。
He had to ask a few times. It got, actually, rather heated. It took a long time, so long that by October, the Senator accused the CIA of obstructionism for failing to get this information to the Senate. And then, finally, just a few days before the congressional vote on the war, he got his report. And when Senator Graham read this report and what it said, he thought it was so important that he asked the intelligence agencies to declassify some of its main conclusions so it could be released to the general public, which he says they agreed to do.
他不得不问了好几次，情况实际上变得相当激烈。这花了很多时间，时间长到十月份时，这位参议员指责中央情报局阻挠，因为他们未能将这些信息提交给参议院。最后，就在国会对战争进行投票的前几天，他拿到了报告。当格雷厄姆参议员读到这份报告及其内容时，他认为这非常重要，于是要求情报机构将其部分主要结论解密，以便公之于众，他说他们同意了。
But it seemed that what they had done is declassify those parts of the report which essentially supported the position that we ought to go to war with Iraq as a first priority. Other pieces of information and analysis which were in the report were not released.
但看起来他们所做的是，仅仅解密了报告中那些实质上支持我们应将对伊战争作为首要任务的立场的部分。报告中其他的分析和信息却没有发布。
So he went back and asked for some of the other material-- the stuff that did not necessarily support the case for war-- to be declassified. And after a few days of wrangling, it finally was. And what it said was this-- and this is actually the part of the story that maybe you've heard if you pay close attention to the news. The intelligence community concluded that Saddam Hussein was not an imminent threat, that he probably would not use his weapons of mass destruction for the foreseeable future-- that was actually the exact phrase they used: for the foreseeable future-- unless we attacked and started to win a war against him. At which point, he probably would use his weapons of mass destruction.
于是他回去要求解密一些其他材料——即那些不一定支持战争理由的内容。经过几天的争执，最终解密了。而报告的内容是这样的——如果你密切关注新闻，这可能就是你听过的那部分故事。情报界得出的结论是，萨达姆·侯赛因并非迫在眉睫的威胁，在可预见的未来，他可能不会使用大规模杀伤性武器——这确实是他们使用的原话：在可预见的未来——除非我们对他发动攻击并开始赢得战争。届时，他很可能会使用大规模杀伤性武器。
When Saddam Hussein reaches the conclusion that all is lost, that he is, in fact, about to be removed from power, at that point, he becomes the most dangerous. And that danger would be reflected in his use of weapons of mass destruction against the invading troops, on neighboring countries. And third, he would likely, 75% or greater chance, form alliances with terrorist groups in order to initiate terrorist attacks against the American people here at home.
当萨达姆·侯赛因断定大势已去，即他实际上即将被赶下台时，在那一刻，他就会变得最危险。这种危险将体现在他对入侵部队或邻国使用大规模杀伤性武器上。第三，他很可能（75%或更高的几率）会与恐怖组织结盟，以便在国内对美国人民发动恐怖袭击。
In other words, if we're going to war to prevent Saddam Hussein from using his weapons of mass destruction, going to war will actually cause the very thing that we're starting the war to prevent. Now it's not like this story didn't get any play. It was in the paper for a day or two. There were reports on radio and television.
换句话说，如果我们发动战争是为了阻止萨达姆·侯赛因使用大规模杀伤性武器，那么发动战争反而会导致我们发起战争所要阻止的事情发生。好吧，这并不是说这个故事没人报道，报纸上曾报道过一两天，广播和电视上也有相关的报道。
But then, after a couple of days, it just kind of dropped off the radar. And at this point, for a politician or for a member of the press to bring it up-- it's hard to bring it up without seeming like you're just out there on the fringe, like you're some kind of extremist, pinko, unpatriotic, like you're against the President, like you are picking a fight.
但之后，过了几天，它就从人们的视线中消失了。此时，如果政治家或新闻界人士再提起这件事，如果不显得自己像是异类、像个极端分子、左派或不爱国，像是在反对总统或故意挑衅，就很难再提起它了。
In the weeks that followed that report coming out, I've sometimes thought about it as I've seen other news stories. And it always has this feeling of, did that really happen? Did that really happen? It's like this event which vanished off the face of the earth, never to be spoken of again. And if you ask Senator Graham, he says that he really thought that declassifying this material would have more impact on the debate over going to war with Iraq.
在那份报告发布后的几周里，我看到其他新闻报道时，有时会想到它。而且它总有一种感觉：那真的发生过吗？那真的发生过吗？就像这件事从地球上消失了，再也没有被提及过一样。如果你问格雷厄姆参议员，他说他确实认为解密这些材料会对有关对伊战争的辩论产生更大的影响。
Yes, I thought that this identification of the danger here in the homeland by an energized group of foreign terrorist agents would have caused us to say, let's reassess what our priorities are. And, in my judgment, such a reassessment would have led to the conclusion that the first thing we should do is to reduce, to the maximum extent possible, the capability of these terrorists who are sleeping among us. And once we had concluded that we had accomplished that objective, then turned to the issue of Iraq.
是的，我本以为这种由一群活跃的外国恐怖代理人对我们本土造成的威胁的鉴定，会促使我们说：“让我们重新评估我们的优先事项。”在我看来，这样的重新评估会得出结论：我们应该做的第一件事是尽可能减少这些潜伏在我们身边的恐怖分子的能力。一旦我们认为已经完成了这一目标，再转而处理伊拉克问题。
Ira, let me ask you a question.
艾拉，让我问你一个问题。
Mm hm.
嗯哼。
I assume you have, or will be talking to people in the administration and asking them questions.
我想你已经或即将与政府人员交谈，并向他们提出问题。
Now, this kind of caught me off guard. At the end of our conversation, Senator Graham told me he had some questions of his own for the administration, that he would like for me to ask them about Saddam using his weapons of mass destruction against us.
这让我有些措手不及。在谈话结束时，格雷厄姆参议员告诉我，他自己对政府有一些问题，希望我能替他问问他们，关于萨达姆对我们使用大规模杀伤性武器的事。
The question that I would ask is, do you have a different assessment of what the consequences of a successful war against Iraq would be than that which has been now made public by the US intelligence community? And then, what are you doing to deal with this potential threat against the people of the United States?
我要问的问题是：你们对成功对伊战争后果的评估，是否与美国情报界目前公布的内容有所不同？如果是，你们正在采取什么措施来应对这一针对美国人民的潜在威胁？
And when you've gone to the administration, and when the committee has posed these questions, what have they told you all?
当你去找政府，当委员会提出这些问题时，他们是怎么回答你们的？
It's just passive and non-responsive, essentially denial, that the most important thing to do now is to take down Saddam Hussein. And if that involves accepting some potential adverse consequences, so be it.
基本上是消极且不予回应，基本上是否认，认为现在最重要的事情就是推翻萨达姆·侯赛因。如果这涉及接受一些潜在的不利后果，那就随它去吧。
So if I can just speak for myself and the staff of this radio program, we're confused. We still have some basic questions about why we're going to war and whether it's a good thing. And we are not alone. In fact, the staff of this radio show is squarely with the majority of Americans on this issue.
所以，如果我可以代表我自己和这个广播节目的制作组发言，我们感到困惑。关于我们为什么要进行战争以及这是否是一件好事，我们仍然有一些基本问题。而且我们并不孤单。事实上，这个广播节目的制作组在这个问题上与大多数美国人是完全一致的。
A Los Angeles Times poll this week revealed that while most Americans support the idea of going to war, we like our president, most of us also feel that the President has not explained why we're doing this. 2/3 of Americans say that he has failed to make a convincing case that war with Iraq is justified. We're with him. We're rooting for him. But we don't know why.
《洛杉矶时报》本周的一项民意调查显示，尽管大多数美国人支持战争的想法，我们也喜欢我们的总统，但我们大多数人也觉得总统并没有解释我们为什么要这样做。三分之二的美国人表示，他未能提出令人信服的理由证明对伊战争是正当的。我们支持他，我们为他加油，但我们不知道原因。
Here are some tourists from around the country at the Rockefeller Center Christmas Tree in New York City.
这里是一些来自全国各地的游客，在纽约市洛克菲勒中心圣诞树前。
I have mixed feelings. I have more issues with bin Laden than I do with what's going on in Iraq.
我心情很复杂。比起伊拉克发生的事情，我更在意本·拉登的问题。
There's other ways to deal with the issue. I don't think that it's compelling enough to go to war.
处理这个问题还有其他方法。我不认为发动战争的理由足够充分。
I haven't really decided yet. I think I'm for it. But I don't know the details.
我还没真正决定。我想我是支持的，但我不知道细节。
I have mixed feelings about it. I want to see proof that there indeed is a threat to the country.
我心情很复杂。我想看到证明，证明国家确实面临威胁。
Today on our program, we step into the breach. We ask a few simple questions about the coming war and get some answers. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. Each week, as you may know, we choose some theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme.
今天在我们的节目中，我们要填补这个空白。我们提出几个关于即将到来的战争的简单问题，并得到一些答案。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司发行。如你所知，每周我们都会选择一个主题，并为你带来各种各样的相关故事。
Today's program, Why We Fight. Our program in four acts. Act One, Senator's Proxy. In that act, we get some poor soul from the administration on the phone to answer Senator Graham's very loaded questions. Act Two, When Firas Comes Marching Home Again, in which we hear from an Iraqi soldier, who might have to fight the United States in the coming war, about what chances he thinks he has against the most powerful military in the history of man. Act Three, Realism 101. We think that it is possible that the most compelling arguments for the war and the most compelling arguments against the war are both arguments that you have not heard. Act Four, Kids' Letters to Santa-- excuse me-- to President Bush. Stay with us.
今天的节目主题是《我们为何而战》。我们的节目分为四幕。第一幕，参议员的代理人。在那一幕中，我们找来政府的一位可怜人通过电话回答格雷厄姆参议员那些非常有倾向性的问题。第二幕，当菲拉斯再次凯旋归来时，我们将听到一位伊拉克士兵的心声，他可能在即将到来的战争中不得不与美国作战，他对自己对抗人类历史上最强大军队的机会怎么看。第三幕，现实主义101。我们认为，战争最有力的论据和反战最有力的论据，可能都是你们从未听说过的。第四幕，孩子们写给圣诞老人的信——抱歉——是写给布什总统的信。请继续收听。
Act One, Senator's Proxy. OK. Let's just say up front that we all take it for granted here that when a politician asks a reporter to go to his political opponent with a question, that is one of the oldest tricks in the book. Having said that, it seemed like a good question. And I have to say, after trying to get an answer from the administration, I understand Senator Graham's frustration. We tried calling five, yes five, different places within our Federal Government: the White House, the National Security Council, the Defense Threat Reduction Agency, the Pentagon's new head of domestic counterterrorism. All of them had the very good sense to turn us down.
第一幕，参议员的代理人。好吧。我们先开门见山地说，我们在这里都认为，当一位政治家要求记者带着问题去质问他的政敌时，这是最古老的伎俩之一。话虽如此，这看起来确实是个好问题。我必须说，在试图从政府那里得到答案后，我理解格雷厄姆参议员的挫败感。我们尝试联系了联邦政府内五个，没错，五个不同的地方：白宫、国家安全委员会、国防威胁降低局、五角大楼新成立的国内反恐主管部门。他们所有人都很有理智地拒绝了我们。
And then, we remembered that President Bush had created an office for this very purpose, the Office of Homeland Security. There, we found somebody who kindly agreed to speak with us, namely--
然后，我们记得布什总统专门为此设立了一个办公室，即国土安全办公室。在那里，我们找到了一个好心同意与我们交谈的人，即——
Gordon Johndroe, spokesman for the White House Office of Homeland Security.
戈登·琼德罗，白宫国土安全办公室发言人。
Now, the intelligence community concluded in October that if we attack Saddam Hussein, if he's cornered, then he'd be likely to use his weapons of mass destruction, his chemical or biological weapons, on troops, on neighboring countries, or here in the United States. And it's that last possibility we wanted to talk to you about. It's of particular concern to Senator Bob Graham from Florida. And he had a question or two he wanted us to ask you.
情报界在十月得出结论称，如果我们攻击萨达姆·侯赛因，如果他被逼入绝境，那么他很可能会对部队、邻国或在美国本土使用他的大规模杀伤性武器，即化学或生物武器。正是这最后一种可能性，我们想和你谈谈。这是来自佛罗里达州的鲍勃·格雷厄姆参议员特别关心的问题。他有一两个问题想让我们代他问你。
[LAUGHS] OK.
[笑] 好吧。
First of all, do you all have a different assessment of the consequences of cornering Saddam Hussein? Do you agree that he might strike here in the US if we start winning the war?
首先，你们对逼入绝境的萨达姆·侯赛因的后果是否有不同的评估？如果我们在战争中开始获胜，你们是否同意他可能会在美国本土发动袭击？
Well, one, the President has made no decision about going to war, he says war is his last resort.
首先，总统尚未决定发动战争，他称战争是最后手段。
Sure.
当然。
But secondly, homeland security agencies will raise our protective measures and take the appropriate actions to address the threat.
但其次，国土安全机构将提高我们的防护措施，并采取适当的行动来应对威胁。
And is it the assessment still of the Office of Homeland Security-- do they agree with the intelligence community, back in October, that if we in fact do go to war, and if in fact we start winning, then the threat is greater here at home?
国土安全办公室是否仍然评估——他们是否同意情报界十月份的评估，即如果我们确实发动了战争，而且确实开始获胜，那么我们国内的威胁会更大？
That is an assessment for the intelligence community to make. And if intelligence suggests that Iraq is planning an attack, and we have information on it, we will respond to that.
那是情报界需要做出的评估。如果情报显示伊拉克正在策划袭击，且我们有相关信息，我们将对此做出回应。
But if one is to take this intelligence assessment seriously, what do you want us to walk away from this with, those of us who've read this in the paper or have heard about this? Do you want us to believe, OK, if we go to war with Iraq, you guys have us covered? We don't need to worry? Or do you want us to think, if we go to war with Iraq, OK, we should all understand we're in a little bit more danger here?
但如果我们要认真对待这一情报评估，你们希望我们从中得到什么结论？那些在报纸上读到或听说过这一点的人。你们希望我们相信“好吧，如果我们与伊拉克开战，你们会保护我们，我们无需担心”？还是你们希望我们认为“如果我们与伊拉克开战，好吧，我们都应该明白我们在国内处于更大的危险中”？
Well, I think that just remains to be seen. And what people need to be reassured is that if that leads to heightened concerns about threats and potential attacks, we will take the appropriate action to meet those threats.
嗯，我认为这还有待观察。人们需要感到放心的是，如果这导致对威胁和潜在袭击的担忧加剧，我们将采取适当行动来应对这些威胁。
And how confident is the Department of Homeland Security that it could stop any threat?
国土安全部对自己能够阻止任何威胁有多大的信心？
What our responsibility is to do is to take action to prevent and protect. And if, unfortunately, we are unable to do that, then we will respond to save as many lives as possible. Recently, we put together all the transactions, all the people that get visas, or all people that cross our borders, or fly into our airports, or containers that come in, and there are about 1.3 billion transactions a year where a terrorist or a terrorist weapon could come into this country. And we have to be right 1.3 billion times a year. And the terrorists only have to be right once.
我们的责任是采取行动进行预防和保护。如果很不幸我们无法做到这一点，那么我们将做出反应，以挽救尽可能多的生命。最近，我们将所有的交易、所有获得签证的人、所有跨越国境、飞进机场的人或入境的集装箱统计了一下，每年大约有13亿次交易，恐怖分子或恐怖武器可能会通过这些渠道进入这个国家。我们必须在每年13亿次的情况下都正确，而恐怖分子只需要成功一次。
That does not sound very reassuring.
听起来不太让人放心。
Well, I think most people would agree, though, that this is a challenge, but that everyone is rising to this challenge.
嗯，我想大多数人都会同意，这是一个挑战，但每个人都在努力应对这一挑战。
When I talked to Senator Graham, he raised this possibility. He wondered if it was the administration's position that you're prepared to accept whatever the consequences will be here in the United States, that it's more important to the country to eliminate Saddam Hussein, and that if some people should die in US cities as a result, well, we don't have a choice. That's the cost of war.
当我和格雷厄姆参议员交谈时，他提出了这种可能性。他想知道政府的立场是否是：你们准备好接受在美国境内发生的任何后果，认为消除萨达姆·侯赛因对国家来说更重要，如果一些人因此在美国城市中丧生，那么我们别无选择，这就是战争的代价。
Well, I would just say that the President's number one responsibility and number one job is protecting the American people.
好吧，我只想说，总统的第一责任和第一职责就是保护美国人民。
Right. But is it--
没错，但这是——
The President is not willing to give up lives, like you say, like Senator Graham says, almost kind of casually in the way that he couched it. And I just-- I take issue with that.
总统不愿放弃生命，像你说的，像格雷厄姆参议员说的那样，他那种措辞几乎显得很随意。对此我不敢苟同。
Well, he was wondering if that was the administration's policy. Is it?
他想知道这是否是政府的政策。是吗？
No, it is not the administration's policy. The administration's policy is to protect Americans.
不，这不是政府的政策。政府的政策是保护美国人。
Gordon Johndroe of the Office of Homeland Security.
国土安全办公室的戈登·琼德罗。
[MUSIC-"MEAN OLD WORLD" BY SAM COOKE]
[音乐-山姆·库克的《残酷的世界》]
Act Two, When Firas Comes Marching Home Again. OK. We're going to continue asking basic questions from people in the United States about why we're going to war in just a few minutes, in Act Three. And we actually get some explanations that do explain it. But before we get to all of that, we wanted to hear some Iraqi perspectives on this.
第二幕，当菲拉斯再次凯旋归来时。我们要继续询问美国民众关于为何要进行战争的基本问题，几分钟后在第三幕。我们实际上得到了一些解释，确实解释了原因。但在讨论这一切之前，我们想听听伊拉克方面的一些观点。
Though, if you've paid even the slightest attention to news reports, you know that it is very difficult for reporters to get anyone in Iraq to speak honestly about the regime or the coming war. They're too frightened of reprisals from the government. There is a huge population of Iraqis who come in and out of the country every day just over the border from Iraq in Jordan. There, they can speak more freely. And Adam Davidson talked to a few of them.
虽然，如果你稍微关注过新闻报道，你就知道记者很难让伊拉克境内的任何人诚实地谈论政权或即将到来的战争。他们太害怕政府的报复了。有大量的伊拉克人每天穿梭于伊拉克和约旦的边境。在那里，他们可以更自由地发言。亚当·戴维森与其中几个人进行了交谈。
If you want to get a sense of how many people are passing back and forth between Jordan and Iraq every day, you just need to go to the eastern part of Amman where there's this gigantic parking lot next to a big highway. The lot is filled with neatly lined up SUVs and Chevrolet Caprices-- the car used by taxi drivers and cops back in the States-- that drive every day, back and forth between Baghdad and Amman. It's hard to understand how they stay so clean. They're all white, except for these orange panels at each corner. They look brand new even though they drive 9 to 12 hours through the desert at least once a day, and often twice.
如果你想了解每天有多少人往返于约旦和伊拉克之间，你只需要去安曼东部，那里有一块紧邻高速公路的巨大停车场。停车场里停满了整齐排列的SUV和雪佛兰Caprices——这是美国出租车司机和警察使用的车——它们每天往返于巴格达和安曼之间。很难理解它们怎么能保持得那么干净。它们全是白色的，角落里有橙色的面板。它们看起来像崭新的一样，尽管它们每天至少要穿过沙漠行驶9到12个小时，通常是两次。
These cars bring hundreds of Iraqi refugees here every day. There are about 150,000 of them in Amman right now, whole neighborhoods filled with nothing but Iraqis. The cars also smuggle cigarettes, family carpets and silverware, dates-- Iraq is famous for its dates-- anything of value. So most things coming from or going to Iraq spend some time in Amman, a lot of them in this parking lot.
这些车每天将数百名伊拉克难民带到这里。目前安曼大约有15万伊拉克人，整个街区住满了伊拉克人。这些车还走私香烟、家庭地毯、银器、椰枣——伊拉克以椰枣闻名——任何有价值的东西。所以大多数进出伊拉克的东西都要在安曼待上一段时间，很多就在这个停车场。
The first Iraqi I run into is Firas, a tall, elegant man in a jalabiya robe and a leather jacket. He sells cloth in Baghdad. And he came to Amman for a few days to meet up with his cousin who has been living abroad, saving money for the family back home in Iraq. Firas tells me he's a reserve soldier. He fought on the front lines of the Iran-Iraq war and the Persian Gulf War. And he knows he'll be called upon soon to fight the Americans.
我遇到的第一个伊拉克人是菲拉斯，一个高大、优雅的男人，穿着阿拉伯长袍和皮夹克。他在巴格达卖布。他来安曼待几天，去见他的表弟，表弟一直住在国外，为伊拉克的家里存钱。菲拉斯告诉我他是预备役士兵。他曾在两伊战争和波斯湾战争的前线作战。他知道他很快就会被征召去对抗美国人。
Have you had special training recently, in the last few months, for this American war?
在过去几个月里，你为这场美国战争接受过特殊训练吗？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
I didn't get any training in the last two years in the Iraqi Army, in any unit, or even any units I knew about from my friends, they didn't have any training in the last two years. But we have enough experience of fighting in the last 15, 20 years with Iran, with the Americans, the Gulf War. We are very well prepared, even without getting any experience or any training to refresh our army or the power of the Iraqi Army today.
我在伊拉克军队中过去两年没有接受过任何训练，在任何部队中，或者我朋友知道的任何部队中，他们过去两年都没有进行过任何训练。但我们在过去15、20年与伊朗、与美国、与波斯湾战争中积累了足够的作战经验。我们准备得非常充分，即使没有经验或训练来更新我们的军队或增强当今伊拉克军队的力量。
Have you gotten orders yet for this war?
你接到这场战争的命令了吗？
[SPEAKING  ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
3, 4 days before the war, usually, they call us to dress and to go to our units. And usually, we do that easily. So we go to the last unit that we served in. And we know where the location is of that. Easily, we can get into there.
通常战争前3、4天，他们会叫我们穿上制服去各自的部队。通常我们很容易做到。我们去上次服役的部队。我们知道位置在哪里。我们可以轻松进入那里。
Now, what we're told in America is that the Iraqi Army-- I don't want to offend you-- but that it's weak right now. It doesn't have the training. It doesn't have the money. It doesn't have the support. And so we're told it will be a tough fight, but we're going to win it very easily.
现在，在美国我们被告知伊拉克军队目前很弱。它没有训练。没有钱。没有支持。所以我们被告知这将是一场艰苦的战斗，但我们会非常轻松地获胜。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
We know that America is a superpower now in the world. Nobody can fight America in the whole world. But what are we going to do? America is going to use the computer wars, and electronic wars, and very strong bombardments. And they will attack us. And they will kill us. But we have to defend ourselves.
我们知道美国现在是世界超级大国。世界上没有人能对抗美国。但我们能做什么呢？美国将使用计算机战、电子战和非常强大的轰炸。他们会攻击我们。他们会杀死我们。但我们必须保护自己。
Do you see Iraqi soldiers preparing for the ground war in Baghdad or in your city?
你看到伊拉克士兵在巴格达或你所在的城市准备地面战争吗？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
We've been in wars in the last 25 years. Do you understand what I mean by 25 years? Almost 2/3 of my age now, of my life. So the Iraqi Army, they're not really prepared for anything, because they are expecting that the Americans will kill them all, and they can't do anything against it. So this is the situation.
过去25年我们一直处于战争中。你明白我所说的25年是什么意思吗？几乎占我现在年龄的三分之二，生命的三分之二。所以伊拉克军队并没有为任何事情真正做好准备，因为他们预料美国人会把他们全部杀死，而他们对此无能为力。所以这就是现状。
I ask him if he thinks he'll die. His reply is what any Muslim might say, that we believe in Allah. We believe in death. Death will come now, or it will come later, Allah decides.
我问他是否认为自己会死。他的回答是任何穆斯林都可能说的话：我们信仰安拉。我们相信死亡。死亡现在会来，或者以后会来，由安拉决定。
I ask him if he'd like Americans to get rid of Saddam. And he tells me Saddam is bad. But whoever the Americans install could be worse. He doesn't expect any good leader to come to Iraq.
我问他是否希望美国人推翻萨达姆。他告诉我萨达姆很坏。但美国人扶植的任何人都可能更坏。他不指望任何好的领导人来到伊拉克。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
Then, Firas says he has to go. He has to help his friend Adnan move some rugs. I ask if I can come along. And we walk a few hundred yards down the road.
然后，菲拉斯说他必须走了。他必须帮朋友阿德南搬一些地毯。我问我能不能一起去。我们沿着路走了几百码。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
These rugs are at least 50 to 60-year-old rugs. So we usually buy them from Iraqi poor people who want to buy food, so they sell their rugs and their carpets. They have them at home.
这些地毯至少有50到60年的历史了。所以我们通常从想买食物的穷困伊拉克人那里买，他们把地毯卖给我们。他们家里有。
Adnan left Baghdad 10 months ago and now oversees this rug smuggling business. We're standing next to a store. I say store, it was really just an empty concrete room about the size of a small garage, packed floor to ceiling with rolled up rugs. Adnan and Firas watch five guys load them onto a truck heading to Saudi Arabia.
阿德南10个月前离开巴格达，现在负责地毯走私业务。我们站在一家店旁边。我说“店”，其实那只是一个大小像小型车库的空混凝土房间，从地板到天花板堆满了卷起来的地毯。阿德南和菲拉斯看着五个人把它们搬上一辆开往沙特阿拉伯的卡车。
Adnan invited us into his apartment. The house is three medium-sized concrete rooms with rugs everywhere. They sleep on rugs in the back. They sit on rugs in the living room, which is completely bare except for the rugs and one plastic chair. We sit, Adnan the rug merchant, Firas the soldier, and a bunch of young 18-ish Iraqi guys who never say a single word, but follow our conversation attentively. Then this Egyptian guy they're all friends with shows up.
阿德南邀请我们去他的公寓。房子里有三个中等大小的混凝土房间，到处都是地毯。他们在后面的地毯上睡觉。他们在客厅的地毯上坐着，客厅除了地毯和一把塑料椅子外什么都没有。我们坐了下来：地毯商阿德南、士兵菲拉斯，还有一群18岁左右的伊拉克小伙子，他们一言不发，但专注地听着我们的对话。然后，他们认识的一个埃及人出现了。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
I want to talk with him about the coming war. But the Egyptian guy launches into all these ready-made speeches about how America wants to destroy Islam, how all Americans hate Arabs, hate Islam. I keep telling him that most Americans don't know anything about Arabs or Islam and don't really care. They just worry about their own lives. He doesn't believe me.
我想和他谈谈即将到来的战争。但这个埃及人开始发表那些陈词滥调，说美国想摧毁伊斯兰教，所有美国人都痛恨阿拉伯人、痛恨伊斯兰教。我一直告诉他，大多数美国人对阿拉伯人或伊斯兰教一无所知，也不怎么关心。他们只关心自己的生活。他不相信我。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
When I look over at the Iraqis, they look completely bored.
当我看向伊拉克人时，他们看起来完全厌倦了。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
Finally, there's a break in the conversation. And I ask the Iraqis what they think. They tell me they don't care about these big issues. They don't care about Islam versus the West, about America's evil plans to destroy all Arabs. Those are just abstractions to them. They know that their homes might be bombed in a few weeks. And they seem genuinely curious to understand anything I can tell them about what Americans are thinking. Here's Firas, the soldier.
终于，谈话出现了停顿。我问伊拉克人他们怎么看。他们告诉我，他们不关心这些大问题。他们不关心伊斯兰教与西方的冲突，不关心美国摧毁所有阿拉伯人的邪恶计划。对他们来说，这些只是抽象的概念。他们知道他们的家园可能会在几周内被轰炸。他们似乎真的很想了解我能告诉他们的任何关于美国人在想什么的事情。这是士兵菲拉斯。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
What's all that issue about Saddam Hussein? Saddam Hussein, the Americans made him bigger than-- give him bigger than his-- his name is much bigger than his size. What does Saddam mean? He's very small. So he's nothing. So why? Americans know things that we don't know here?
萨达姆·侯赛因到底是个什么问题？萨达姆·侯赛因，美国人把他塑造得比……他的名字比他实际的规模大得多。萨达姆算什么？他很渺小。所以他什么都不是。那么，为什么？美国人知道我们这里不知道的事情？
Firas is sure the guy is bad. But there are worse people, like the North Koreans. And I don't know what to say to him. So I stumble around like an idiot, trying to explain American foreign policy, which I honestly don't understand myself, to people whose families might be bombed-- another conversation you find yourself in with disturbing frequency around here.
菲拉斯确定这个家伙很坏。但有比他更坏的人，比如北韩人。我不知道该对他说什么。所以我像个白痴一样结结巴巴，试图向那些家人可能遭到轰炸的人解释美国的外交政策——我自己其实也不明白。在这附近，你会频繁地陷入这种令人不安的谈话中。
I mean, I find it very confusing myself. I think there are few-- George Bush-- it's very hard to fight--
我是说，我觉得这非常令人困惑。我觉得有一些——乔治·布什——这很难对抗——
Then Adnan, the rug merchant, tells me that most Iraqis he knows support a war. They want America to get rid of Saddam. But they're worried. He says, and I've heard this a lot, that the uprising against Saddam after the Gulf War was very real and widespread. And the Americans just abandoned them.
然后地毯商阿德南告诉我，他认识的大多数伊拉克人都支持战争。他们希望美国除掉萨达姆。但他们很担心。他说——我听过很多次这种说法——波斯湾战争后针对萨达姆的起义是真实且广泛的。而美国人只是抛弃了他们。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
We are with the Americans if they are true, if they're not going to change their mind now. We are with them 100%. But we are afraid. And Saddam is really preparing and now having groups of terrorists. And they are ready to attack the Americans, American soldiers, and American troops, and American civilians in most of the Arab countries during the war.
如果美国人是真心的，如果他们现在不会改变主意，我们就支持他们。我们百分之百支持他们。但我们害怕。萨达姆确实在准备，现在有恐怖组织。他们准备在战争期间在大多数阿拉伯国家袭击美国人、美国士兵、美国军队和美国平民。
This, of course, is exactly what American intelligence has been predicting since October.
这当然就是美国情报界自十月以来一直预测的情况。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
Adnan then, more or less, begs me to tell all of America about his best friend who was taken away by Saddam's Mukhabarat secret police and killed just because he started a home prayer group. Adnan tells me to use his real name and his friend's real name and to take his picture, things Iraqis usually won't do with the press, and which, in the end, I decided not to do. But Adnan is so sick and tired of the situation, he doesn't care what happens. He just wants the truth out.
阿德南随后几乎是恳求我向全美国讲述他最好的朋友的事，他被萨达姆的穆哈巴拉特秘密警察抓走并杀害，只因为他发起了一个家庭祈祷小组。阿德南让我使用他的真实姓名和他朋友的真实姓名，并拍摄他的照片——这些事伊拉克人通常不会在媒体面前做，而最后，我决定不这么做。但阿德南对现状厌倦到了极点，他不在乎会发生什么。他只想让真相大白。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
So Saddam Hussein is a man of violence. Saddam Hussein killed his people. Saddam Hussein used chemicals against his people. Saddam Hussein used biological against his people. So fear is the principle of our life today in Iraq.
所以萨达姆·侯赛因是一个崇尚暴力的男人。萨达姆·侯赛因杀害了他的人民。萨达姆·侯赛因对人民使用了化学武器。萨达姆·侯赛因对人民使用了生物武器。所以恐惧是我们今天在伊拉克生活的原则。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
While he's saying this, Firas, the soldier, starts looking nervous. He's going back to Baghdad in a few days. And my guess is that he doesn't want to say anything that will get him in trouble. And so I turn to him.
当他在说这些时，士兵菲拉斯开始显得很紧张。几天后他就要回巴格达了。我的猜测是他不想说任何会让他惹上麻烦的话。所以我转向他。
You don't want to talk about this stuff, do you?
你不想谈论这些事情，对吗？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
I've never heard of these things before.
我以前从没听说过这些事情。
He looks directly in my eyes, smiling as he says this. Basically, you know what I'm doing. I know what I'm doing. Everyone knows what I'm doing. He adds that he's happy with Saddam, but he doesn't know what the other guys think. Saddam Hussein is such a peaceful man, he says. He doesn't even know he invaded Kuwait. [LAUGHTER]
他说这句话时，直视着我的眼睛，面带微笑。基本上，你知道我在做什么。我也知道我在做什么。每个人都知道我在做什么。他补充说他对萨达姆感到满意，但他不知道其他人怎么想。他说，萨达姆·侯赛因是一个如此和平的人。他甚至不知道自己入侵了科威特。[笑声]
They're laughing, you know? Saddam Hussein didn't hear about his army invading Kuwait. [LAUGHS] He's a very peaceful person.
他们在笑，你明白吗？萨达姆·侯赛因没听说他的军队入侵了科威特。[笑] 他是一个非常和平的人。
There are so many Iraqis here, and they're so desperate. It's amazing who you meet and what they say to you. A couple days later, when Omar and I are walking around a different Iraqi neighborhood a young guy sees my microphone, comes up to us, and talks fast in Arabic. He says he was one of Saddam's personal bodyguards and would like to help the Americans kill him. He wants to talk to me, he says. But he can't do it in his neighborhood because people might turn him in to the Iraqis.
这里的伊拉克人太多了，他们太绝望了。遇到的人以及他们说的话真是令人惊叹。几天后，当我和奥马尔在另一个伊拉克社区走动时，一个年轻人看到了我的麦克风，朝我们走来，用阿拉伯语快速交谈。他说他是萨达姆的私人保镖之一，愿意帮助美国人杀了他。他说他想和我谈谈。但他不能在自己的社区做，因为人们可能会把他交给伊拉克人。
I invite him to my hotel. And he comes along. He asked me not to use his real name, or his voice, for that matter. It's just too dangerous. So I'll call him Nabil. And you'll only hear Omar's translation.
我邀请他去我的旅馆。他跟了过来。他要求我不要使用他的真名，甚至不要使用他的声音。这太危险了。所以我叫他纳比尔。你只能听到奥马尔的翻译。
Nabil is a big guy, fat and tall. But he holds himself like an elite soldier. He sits in my room and tells me a lot about Saddam's palaces. He said that one of Saddam's palaces, Saddam's favorite, has a giant glass floor built on top of a huge aquarium with sharks and giant fish. Later, I check into this, and it's true. His life was great when he guarded Saddam. Saddam personally gave him a grand apartment.
纳比尔是个大块头，又胖又高。但他保持着精英士兵的姿态。他坐在我的房间里，告诉我很多关于萨达姆宫殿的事。他说萨达姆最喜欢的宫殿之一有一个巨大的玻璃地板，建在一个巨大的水族馆之上，里面有鲨鱼和巨大的鱼。后来，我核实了这件事，是真的。他在守卫萨达姆时生活得很好。萨达姆亲自给了他一套豪华公寓。
What was he like? Did you get to know him? Was he ever funny? Did you like him?
他是什么样的人？你了解他吗？他幽默吗？你喜欢他吗？
It seems that Saddam Hussein has a special personality, unique personality. When you come to look at him on the TV, you come to hate him. For all the things that he made for the people, you come to hate him.
萨达姆·侯赛因似乎有一种特殊的个性，独特的个性。当你在电视上看到他时，你开始恨他。因为他为人民所做的一切，你开始恨他。
But when you come close to him, and you just come one meter, two meters from him, you just change your mind. Different feelings usually come to your mind. Different feelings come to your body. Different feelings come to your eyes when you look at him. When you come very close to him, it seems that there is magic in this personality and in this man.
但当你接近他，当你只离他一米、两米远时，你就改变了主意。通常会有不同的感觉涌上心头。不同的感觉进入你的身体。当你看着他时，你的眼睛里会有不同的感觉。当你非常靠近他时，似乎这种个性和这个人有一种魔力。
Nabil quit the army when his term was over. And a few days later was arrested by the Mukhabarat, the secret police, and taken to a prison for divulging secrets about Saddam's palaces. He tells me that it wasn't true what he was accused of. It was trumped up.
纳比尔在任期结束后退出了军队。几天后，他被穆哈巴拉特（秘密警察）逮捕，带到一个监狱，原因是他泄露了关于萨达姆宫殿的秘密。他告诉我他被指控的事情并非事实。那是捏造的。
But still, they beat him with steel pipes, badly. He shows me his arm and forehead where the bones haven't healed properly. Half his teeth are bashed in and haven't been fixed. He says that he was in jail for weeks and finally was released, but was then told by a friend that he was targeted for death. So he escaped to Amman. He said he was always a healthy man, but now he just smokes and drinks coffee and thinks of ways to kill Saddam.
但他们仍然用钢管狠狠地殴打他。他给我看了他的手臂和额头，骨头没有正常愈合。他的一半牙齿被打断了，还没修复。他说他在监狱里待了几个星期，最后被释放了，但随后被朋友告知他已被列为暗杀目标。于是他逃到了安曼。他说他一直是个健康的人，但现在他只是抽烟、喝咖啡，并思考杀掉萨达姆的方法。
You said you want to help the Americans. Have you tried to make contact with the Americans?
你说你想帮助美国人。你尝试过与美国人联系吗？
I'm always scared, because I don't know if the Mukhabarat are watching me now or not. I don't know when they're going to kill me. I don't know whom I have to contact. But if anybody wants to use me-- and for sure I know everything. I know where are all the weapons are that they took from Kuwait, where it is now. And I know where the stores are, where they store it, in the north, and the south, and in the center of Iraq.
我总是很害怕，因为我不知道穆哈巴拉特现在是否在监视我。我不知道他们什么时候会杀我。我不知道该联系谁。但如果有人想利用我——我确实什么都知道。我知道他们从科威特拿走的所有武器都在哪里，现在在哪里。我知道商店在哪里，他们把武器储存在哪里，在伊拉克的北部、南部和中部。
Of course, there's no way to tell if he's credible or not without going into Iraq and doing inspections. So Hans Blix, here's what he's got. He told me there are weapons of mass destruction. And they're sitting in giant, movable bunkers under the sand dunes in a suburb of Tikrit. He didn't want money or any special privileges. He just wanted to talk to somebody.
当然，如果不去伊拉克进行视察，就无法判断他是否可信。所以汉斯·布利克斯，这就是他所掌握的。他告诉我确实有大规模杀伤性武器。它们就放在提克里特郊区沙丘下的巨大可移动掩体里。他不要钱，也不要任何特殊待遇。他只是想找个人谈谈。
The next day, I go to the Iraqi Embassy in Amman, because part of the reason why I'm here is that I'm trying to get into Baghdad like all the other reporters. In the past two weeks, I've probably spent 30 hours at the embassy waiting to get a visa. Usually, a bunch of US reporters sit in a clump in the lobby, and nobody talks to us. But that day, an old man came up to me and my translator and said he'd like to tell us things about Saddam. I told him he shouldn't be talking to me in the embassy. And he agreed to meet us the next night.
第二天，我去了安曼的伊拉克大使馆，因为我在这里的部分原因是像其他记者一样想进入巴格达。在过去的两周里，我大概在大使馆花了30个小时等待签证。通常，一群美国记者坐在大厅里挤成一团，没人理我们。但那天，一个老人走到我和我的翻译面前，说他想告诉我们关于萨达姆的事情。我告诉他不应该在大使馆和我谈话。他同意第二天晚上见面。
So the next night, my translator, Omar, and I pick him up at a gas station in a poor Iraqi neighborhood and take him to Omar's house. He tells me he was a famous dancer in Iraq. He has that sort of regal, straight-backed dancer's presence. He says he used to be in charge of several major theaters. And every year, he put on the big birthday celebration for Saddam. He met the man several times and had a very nice life. Then, his brother was killed for being loyal to one of Saddam's opponents, and the dancer came under suspicion.
第二天晚上，我的翻译奥马尔和我开车在一个贫穷的伊拉克社区接上他，带他回奥马尔的家。他告诉我他曾经是伊拉克著名的舞蹈家。他有一种那种高贵的、腰杆笔直的舞者的气质。他说他过去负责几家大剧院。每年，他都会为萨达姆筹办盛大的生日庆典。他见过那个人好几次，生活非常美好。然后，他的兄弟因为效忠萨达姆的对手而被杀，舞蹈家也受到了怀疑。
[SPEAKING  ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
They beat me in the minister's office. And then, they called the Mukhabarat intelligence. And they took me in a van. And three people, they beat me until we arrived at the police station. And after that, I was in the Mukhabarat. There, I couldn't sleep for more than 30 days. They put me in a small prison, one meter by one meter. I couldn't realize if it's dark or light, if it's night or day. And I stayed there for three years.
他们在部长的办公室殴打我。然后，他们叫来了穆哈巴拉特情报部门。他们用一辆货车把我带走。三个人，他们一直打我，直到我们到达警察局。之后，我被关在穆哈巴拉特。在那里，我超过30天无法入睡。他们把我关在一个一米乘一米的狭小监狱里。我无法分辨是黑是亮，是夜是昼。我在那里待了三年。
His story doesn't get any better. Not only did they constantly beat him, but they cut his right ear in half, broke his legs, his arms, his hands, and put knives in his back. One day, he says, Saddam's son, Uday, came by and oversaw the torture. At one point, he made the man take off all his clothes and told him, you're a dancer. You have to dance now.
他的故事没好到哪里去。他们不仅不断殴打他，还割掉了他的右耳，打断了他的腿、手臂、手，还在他的背上捅了刀子。有一天，他说，萨达姆的儿子乌代过来监督拷打。有一次，他让那个男人脱光衣服，对他说：“你是舞蹈家。你现在必须跳舞。”
[SPEAKING  ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
Yes, of course, they cut all his fingers. They broke all my fingers.
是的，当然，他们剪掉了他所有的手指。他们打断了我所有的手指。
They look like they've been broken, yeah.
它们看起来确实被打断了，是的。
The nails. They took the nails, yeah.
指甲。他们取下了指甲，是的。
He just pulled his fingers to show how they pulled it. And you can see that his nails are not put-- you can see that his nails are not-- they're scarred all around. God, it's so upsetting to look at his hands. It's just so upsetting looking at him. His hands are just-- they look like they were broken and put back together.
他只是拉了拉自己的手指来展示他们是如何拉出来的。你可以看到他的指甲没有被——你可以看到他的指甲没有被——它们四周都是疤痕。天哪，看着他的手真是太让人难过了。看着他真是太让人难过了。他的手只是——看起来像是被打断了又接回去的。
[SPEAKING  ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
After he left prison, he went to find his wife and discovered that she had been taken and killed because she screamed bad things about Saddam in the street after he was arrested. Then, his six-year-old son died from some untreated illness. The man is now homeless and told me he was walking the streets, begging for money when he came upon the Iraqi Embassy.
出狱后，他去找妻子，发现她被抓走了，并被杀害了，因为她在被捕后在街上尖叫萨达姆的坏话。然后，他六岁的儿子死于某种未治疗的疾病。这个男人现在无家可归，告诉我他当时走在街上，乞求钱财，偶然来到了伊拉克大使馆。
He decided to just go in, sit down, and wait for someone to arrest him and kill him. He says that's when he saw us and decided to stay alive a little bit longer. Maybe our interview would help somehow. At one point, he pulled out an article about himself from eight years ago, just eight years ago. I thought it was 30 years old. In the picture, he looks so young and happy and healthy, standing proudly in front of a group of his dance students.
他决定进去，坐下来，等着有人来逮捕他并杀死他。他说那是他看到我们并决定多活一会儿的时候。也许我们的采访能有某种帮助。有一次，他拿出了一篇关于他八年前——仅仅八年前——的报道文章。我原以为是30年前的。在照片中，他看起来是那么年轻、快乐和健康，骄傲地站在一群他的舞蹈学生面前。
And he started to beat me.
然后他开始打我。
The old man spoke softly, calmly, crying a little bit every now and then. And while he talked, my translator, Omar's, eyes were wet. He could barely speak the words.
老人说话声音柔和、平静，不时哭泣。当他说话时，我的翻译奥马尔的眼睛湿润了。他几乎说不出话来。
If I could say a word about what it's been like to talk to all these people, I came to the middle east thinking this war that's coming is a terrible thing. I still don't really understand why we're doing it. But I feel sick. I really, actually have had a stomach ache this whole week talking to these Iraqis, hearing what Saddam Hussein has done to his people.
如果我能说一句和这些人谈话的感受，我带着认为这场即将到来的战争是一件可怕的事情的念头来到中东。我仍然不太明白我们为什么要这样做。但我感到恶心。整个这一周和这些伊拉克人谈话，听萨达姆·侯赛因对他的人民做了什么，我实际上真的胃疼。
One woman sobbed as she told me about her son who was killed because he wouldn't fight in the Persian Gulf War. A middle-aged man explained how members of the regime took food from his grocery store until he protested, and they beat him and threw him in jail for a year. Now, he sits in a room all day in Amman with his wife and six kids, because he's too afraid he'll be deported back to Iraq where he'd be killed. After talking to all these Iraqi exiles, I want Saddam Hussein to die.
一位妇女在告诉我她儿子被杀的事时抽泣，只因为他不愿在波斯湾战争中作战。一位中年男子解释说，政权成员如何从他的杂货店拿走食物，直到他抗议，他们殴打了他并将他投入监狱一年。现在，他和妻子以及六个孩子整天待在安曼的一个房间里，因为他太害怕如果被驱逐回伊拉克会被杀掉。在和所有这些伊拉克流亡者谈话后，我希望萨达姆·侯赛因去死。
I asked pretty much every Iraqi if they fantasize about life after Saddam, if they ever think, wow, in three or four months, he might be dead, my country might be free? Not one said they think about it. They're too tired. And Saddam Hussein has been there for so long, they just can't imagine life without him. I just hope we do the right thing, that if there's a war, whatever ruler ends up running Iraq is a good man.
我几乎问了每一个伊拉克人，他们是否幻想萨达姆之后的生活，他们是否会想，哇，三四个月后他可能就死了，我的国家可能就自由了？没有一个人说他们会那样想。他们太累了。萨达姆·侯赛因在那里待了太久，他们根本无法想象没有他的生活。我只希望我们做正确的事，如果发生战争，无论最终谁来经营伊拉克，那个人都是好人。
Adam Davidson in Amman, Jordan. Coming up, Dear Mr. President, my birthday is November 12. And I'll be 15, so if you are president, you'll get me something, and other kids' letters to George Bush in this time of war. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
亚当·戴维森在约旦安曼。接下来是《亲爱的总统先生，我的生日是11月12日。我将满15岁，所以如果你是总统，你应该送我东西》，以及在这个战争时代孩子们写给乔治·布什的其他信。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Why We Fight, stories trying to understand the coming war with Iraq, or should I say, the likely war with Iraq? We've arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, Realism 101.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，并为你带来各种各样的相关故事。今天的节目《我们为何而战》，试图理解即将到来的对伊战争的故事，或者我应该说，极有可能发生的对伊战争？我们已经进入了节目的第三幕。第三幕，现实主义101。
All right. Right now the administration is throwing around a number of arguments for the war, which I'm guessing are familiar to all of us at this point: Iraq's links to Al Qaeda, Iraq breaking a lot of UN resolutions, the ever popular, Saddam tried to kill my daddy. But at its heart, the case comes down to the idea that it is only a matter of time before Saddam Hussein gets a nuclear weapon. And when he does, it'll be a disaster for us and for the world.
好了。现在政府正在抛出许多开战的理由，我想这些理由对我们大家来说都已经很熟悉了：伊拉克与基地组织的联系，伊拉克违反了许多联合国决议，永远受欢迎的“萨达姆试图杀死我的爸爸”。但归根结底，这个理由归结为：萨达姆·侯赛因获得核武器只是时间问题。一旦他拥有核武器，那将是我们和全世界的灾难。
Well it turns out that the most interesting, and maybe the most compelling argument against the war in Iraq hasn't actually gotten a lot of attention in the public debate, in Congress or in the media. And one of the things that's interesting about the argument is that it does not come from a bunch of lefty peaceniks. No, no, no, it comes from a group of foreign policy experts who look at the tough guys in the administration and think they are not tough enough. It's a school of thinking called the Realists. Back in September, a journalist named Nicholas Lemann wrote an article in The New Yorker magazine explaining the Realists, which is how we heard of them.
事实证明，关于伊拉克战争最有趣，也许是最有力的反战理由，实际上并没有在公众辩论、国会或媒体中得到太多关注。这个论点有趣的地方在于，它不是来自一群左派和平主义者。不，不，不，它来自一群外交政策专家，他们看着政府里的硬汉，认为他们还不够强硬。这是一种被称为“现实主义者”的思想流派。早在九月，一位名叫尼古拉斯·莱曼的记者在《纽约客》杂志上写了一篇文章来解释“现实主义者”，这就是我们听说他们的方式。
Within the foreign policy world, these arguments against war are totally in circulation, and they're talked about a great deal. In the wider world, where politicians say things to the public, the case against the war is still not really in circulation. And it looks like it may never be.
在外交政策领域，这些反战论点完全在流传，并且被讨论得很多。在更广阔的世界里，政治家们对公众说些什么，反战理由仍然没有真正流传开来。看起来它可能永远不会。
What we're going to do now is run through some of the arguments that are put forward by the Realists, which are pretty convincing. And then, we're going to hear some of the arguments against them, which I have to say, are also pretty convincing. And we're going to do all this because a lot of this just has not been in general circulation. When I was doing the interviews for this story, I was constantly surprised at what I was hearing from both sides. And I'm guessing that might be true for you also.
我们现在要做的是梳理一下现实主义者提出的论点，这些论点相当令人信服。然后，我们要听听反对他们的论点，我必须说，这些论点也相当令人信服。我们做这一切是因为很多内容根本没有在一般民众中传播。在为这个故事采访时，我不断地对两边听到的内容感到惊讶。我想这对你可能也适用。
OK. So let's start. To give you a sense of just how different the Realists are from everyone else in the public debate, you can just start with this: Pretty much every politician, every commentator on television and radio, every mainstream voice out there accepts as a given that there should be a war on terror. As Nicholas Lemann points out, the war on terrorism has framed the way that we all think about these things. It's entered the language. We take it for granted. At this point, it just seems like the logical, inevitable response to the September 11 attacks to most everyone, except the Realists. They oppose the War on Terror.
好了。那么开始吧。为了让你了解现实主义者与公众辩论中的其他人有多么不同，你可以从这一点开始：几乎每一位政治家，电视和广播中的每一位评论员，外面每一位主流的声音，都默认应该有一场反恐战争。正如尼古拉斯·莱曼指出的，反恐战争已经构成了我们所有人思考这些事情的方式。它已经进入了语言。我们认为这是理所当然的。在这一点上，除现实主义者外，对几乎所有人来说，这似乎是九一一袭击后的逻辑、不可避免的反应。他们反对反恐战争。
I'll say that again. They oppose the War on Terror. And they oppose it on practical grounds. They think it's ill conceived. And they think it won't work.
我再说一遍。他们反对反恐战争。他们从实际角度反对它。他们认为它是构思不当的。他们认为它不会奏效。
I think he should have declared a narrow war on Al Qaeda. To declare war on terror defines a war on a whole lot of groups out there in the world, a lot of whom have never taken a swing at the United States, don't intend to take a swing at the United States. We need to keep our eye on the ball and not get distracted.
我认为他应该宣布一场针对基地组织的有限战争。宣布反恐战争定义了对世界上很多团体的战争，其中很多团体从未对美国采取行动，也不打算对美国采取行动。我们需要关注主要目标，不要分心。
This is Stephen Van Evera, a specialist in international affairs and security issues at MIT.
这是斯蒂芬·范·埃弗拉，麻省理工学院国际事务和安全问题专家。
When you say you're going to war with terror that means, hey, who's your enemy out there? The FARC in Colombia, and the terrorists in China, Chechnya, you name it. We don't need more enemies. We need to focus on the danger we face.
当你说你要和恐怖主义开战时，意味着，嘿，谁是你的敌人？哥伦比亚的哥伦比亚革命武装力量，以及中国、车臣的恐怖分子，诸如此类。我们不需要更多的敌人。我们需要关注我们面临的危险。
And how's the War on Terror going?
那么反恐战争进展如何？
Poorly. It's going poorly if you look at objective measures. Al Qaeda is still out there. They're still strong. They're still able to land a big punch. We've only caught about 40% of their top leaders, which is a disaster 15 months into the war. The CIA warns us that they're as capable as they were before 9/11, that the threat they pose is as large as it was before 9/11. So if you look at it objectively, we're not doing well.
糟糕。如果你看客观指标，进展很糟糕。基地组织仍然在那里。他们依然强大。他们仍然有能力给予重击。我们只抓住了他们大约40%的高层领导人，在战争开始15个月后，这简直是一场灾难。中情局警告我们，他们像9/11之前一样有能力，他们构成的威胁和9/11之前一样大。所以如果你客观地看，我们做得并不好。
Are you worried? Are you frightened by the focus on Iraq at the expense of Al Qaeda?
你担心吗？你对以牺牲对基地组织的打击为代价而关注伊拉克感到害怕吗？
Yes, I am. I am unsold on this war in Iraq. I think Saddam's a horrible fellow, and a nasty guy, and a threat, but Al Qaeda poses a much more serious threat.
是的，我担心。我不赞成这场对伊战争。我认为萨达姆是个可怕的家伙，是个令人讨厌的家伙，也是个威胁，但基地组织构成了严重得多的威胁。
When it comes to Iraq, the Realists not only point out all the practical problems with the war-- that it might lead to huge problems in Pakistan, which has nuclear weapons that could end up in the wrong hands, that we could bungle the occupation after we win. What they see in Afghanistan, they do not find encouraging. But beyond that, they question the central reason for the war. And again, they do it on grounds that have not gotten a lot of attention publicly.
当谈到伊拉克时，现实主义者不仅指出了战争的所有实际问题——这可能会导致巴基斯坦出现巨大问题，而巴基斯坦拥有的核武器可能落入坏人之手；我们可能会在获胜后搞砸占领。他们在阿富汗看到的，并不觉得令人鼓舞。但除此之外，他们质疑战争的核心原因。再一次，他们质疑的理由并没有在公众中得到太多关注。
The administration's central argument, as you know, is that we have to stop Saddam Hussein before he gets nuclear weapons. The Realists say, if he gets nuclear weapons, so what? So what?
如你所知，政府的核心论点是，我们必须在萨达姆·侯赛因获得核武器之前阻止他。现实主义者说：如果他获得了核武器，那又怎样？那又怎样？
I believe that Iraq, even if it had weapons of mass destruction, including nuclear weapons, would not be able to do very much with those weapons.
我相信伊拉克即使拥有包括核武器在内的大规模杀伤性武器，也无法利用这些武器做太多事情。
That's Steven Walt from Harvard, another Realist.
那是哈佛大学的斯蒂芬·沃尔特，另一位现实主义者。
And the reason it can't is because it cannot threaten to use them without facing retaliation from the United States or from others. There's good historical evidence suggesting that Saddam Hussein, like other dictators before him, can easily be contained and deterred. If you look at the historical record, this is a government that has only used force when they were vulnerable, when they were feeling threatened, and, most importantly, when they felt their opponents were isolated.
原因在于它无法威胁使用这些武器，而不面临来自美国或其他国家的报复。有很好的历史证据表明，萨达姆·侯赛因和在他之前的其他独裁者一样，可以很容易地被遏制和威慑。如果你看历史记录，这是一个只有在脆弱、感到受威胁，最重要的是，感到对手被孤立时才会使用武力的政府。
So if you go back to the Iran-Iraq war, this is a case where the Iranians were the aggressors, were actively trying to overthrow the Iraqi regime, and yet were also isolated and appeared to be vulnerable. So he fought. Similarly, the Gulf War, the invasion of Kuwait, they had serious financial problems. The Kuwaitis were playing various games with oil quotas that were helping keep Iraq weak and vulnerable. And most importantly, we gave them, I think, an inadvertent green light, the famous April Glaspie interview where she says, we, the United States, have no interest in inter-Arab disputes, such as the border dispute between Kuwait and Iraq.
所以回到两伊战争，这是一个伊朗人作为侵略者，积极试图推翻伊拉克政权，但同时又被孤立且看起来很脆弱的案例。所以他作战了。同样，波斯湾战争，对科威特的入侵，他们有严重的财政问题。科威特人在石油配额上玩各种把戏，这有助于保持伊拉克的虚弱和脆弱。最重要的是，我认为我们无意中给了他们绿灯，著名的艾普丽尔·格拉斯比采访，她说：“我们，美国，对阿拉伯国家间的争端没有兴趣，比如科威特和伊拉克之间的边界纠纷。”
She was a US ambassador in the region that--
她是该地区的美国大使——
That's correct. She was the US Ambassador in Baghdad. And I don't think we intended to signal him that we weren't interested in Kuwaiti security. But that is, in effect, what we did. The lesson of the Gulf War is not that he can't be deterred. It's that we didn't even try to deter him.
没错。她是美国驻巴格达大使。我不认为我们打算向他发出信号说我们对科威特的安全不感兴趣。但实际上，我们就是那样做了。波斯湾战争的教训不是他无法被威慑，而是我们甚至没有尝试去威慑他。
OK. Let's just stop that tape right there. As you've probably noticed, this is a very different Saddam Hussein than we're used to hearing about. He's not a madman. He's not hell-bent on territorial expansion and bullying other countries around. He's rational-- rational enough to heed warnings from others. And Stephen Walt knows that all of this sounds just a little bit funny to basically any civilian like you and me that he ever talks to about this.
好了。我们就在这里停一下带子。正如你可能注意到的，这是一个与我们通常听到的完全不同的萨达姆·侯赛因。他不是一个疯子。他不是一心想进行领土扩张并欺凌其他国家。他是理性的——理性到足以听从他人的警告。而斯蒂芬·沃尔特知道，他与之谈论此事的任何像你我这样的普通民众，都会觉得所有这一切听起来有点可笑。
I don't mean to be an apologist for Saddam Hussein at all. He is in fact a brutal despot. But if you look at his foreign policy conduct, like many despots in the past, such as Joseph Stalin or Mao Zedong, he's actually quite concerned with his own personal survival and quite concerned with the survival and security of his regime. That has made him actually relatively prudent in using force.
我根本无意为萨达姆·侯赛因辩护。他实际上是一个残酷的暴君。但如果你观察他的外交政策行为，像过去的许多独裁者，如约瑟夫·斯大林或毛泽东一样，他实际上非常关心自己个人的生存，也非常关心自己政权的生存和安全。这实际上使他在使用武力方面相对审慎。
The other point to note is, this is a man who's never used weapons of mass destruction against anyone who could retaliate. He used them against the Iranians who had no such weapons themselves. And he used them against the Kurdish population in Iraq, also a group that couldn't retaliate. He's never tried to use weapons of mass destruction against us, against the Israelis, against the Saudis.
另一点需要指出的是，这是一个从未对任何能够报复的人使用过大规模杀伤性武器的人。他对伊朗人使用了它们，而伊朗人自己没有任何此类武器。他对伊拉克境内的库尔德人使用了它们，这也是一个无法报复的群体。他从未试图对我们、对以色列人、对沙特人使用大规模杀伤性武器。
I saw in something you wrote that you quoted some of his generals, who said the reason why chemical and biological weapons weren't used during the Persian Gulf War was precisely because he had been warned, and he didn't want to allow for retaliation.
我在你写的东西中看到，你引用了一些他的将军的话，他们说，在波斯湾战争期间没有使用化学和生物武器的原因，正是因为他受到了警告，他不想引发报复。
That's correct. We sent a very explicit message, I believe in a letter from Secretary of State James Baker, communicated through the Iraqi Foreign Minister, that if they were to use weapons of mass destruction against us, we would not limit ourselves to retaliation in kind. I forget the exact wording. But it was an unmistakable threat, which the Iraqis seem to have heeded. And some Iraqi officials have said our warning was part of the reason why they didn't use it.
正确。我们发出了一个非常明确的信息，我相信是在国务卿詹姆斯·贝克的一封信中，通过伊拉克外交部长传达的，如果他们对我们使用大规模杀伤性武器，我们将不会仅仅限于同等报复。我忘了具体的措辞。但这是一种毫无疑问的威胁，伊拉克人似乎注意到了。一些伊拉克官员表示，我们的警告是他们没有使用它的部分原因。
All right. You still with me here? Now, remember, I said that we were going to get to the arguments against the Realists. And we looked for the most convincing spokesman for the other side. And we were lucky enough to get our very first pick, Kenneth Pollack, who was a Persian Gulf military analyst for seven years at the CIA, including during the Persian Gulf War, and after that, for the National Security Council under President Clinton. He's now at the Saban Center for Middle East Policy at the Brookings Institution. He's written a book called The Threatening Storm: the Case for Invading Iraq . And when I recited to him the Realist case, chapter and verse, that Saddam Hussein could be deterred from using a nuclear weapon, he nearly sputtered. He honestly did not know where to begin.
好了。你还在听我讲吗？现在，记得我说过我们要讨论反对现实主义者的论点吗？我们寻找了对方最有说服力的发言人。我们很幸运地得到了我们的第一选择，肯尼斯·波拉克。他在中情局担任波斯湾军事分析员七年，包括波斯湾战争期间，此后在克林顿总统领导下的国家安全委员会工作。他现在在布鲁金斯学会的中东政策萨班中心。他写了一本书叫《威胁的风暴：入侵伊拉克的理由》。当我向他背诵现实主义者的理由（逐章、逐条），即萨达姆·侯赛因可以被威慑而不会使用核武器时，他几乎要喷出来了。他真的不知道从哪里开始。
Boy, we're going to be here a while. The arguments that they're mustering are based on simply incorrect information. Their understanding of Saddam Hussein's decision making is just deeply flawed. We know a huge amount about Saddam's decision making in some of these cases. And it simply doesn't square with their arguments-- for example, the invasion of Kuwait.
天哪，我们要在这里待上一会儿了。他们提出的论点建立在完全不正确的信息基础上。他们对萨达姆·侯赛因决策的理解存在严重缺陷。我们在其中一些案例中对萨达姆的决策了解非常多。这与他们的论点完全不符——例如，入侵科威特。
Good idea. Let's start with the invasion of Kuwait. Pollack disputes even the basic facts that the Realists offer on this. He says that we know now that Saddam had decided to invade before the American Ambassador indicated to him, inadvertently, that we wouldn't fight back. He says that we know now that Saddam did not attack Kuwait as some kind of modest, rational act of aggression, but as the first step in a larger plan of his to becoming a kind of superpower.
好主意。让我们从入侵科威特开始。波拉克甚至对现实主义者提供的基本事实提出了质疑。他说我们现在知道萨达姆在美国大使无意中暗示我们不会反击之前就已经决定入侵了。他说我们现在知道萨达姆袭击科威特并非什么温和、理性的侵略行为，而是他成为超级大国计划的第一步。
Even before the invasion of Kuwait, Saddam was already saying, the demise of the Soviet Union leaves the world badly unbalanced. Iraq has to become a new superpower to be able to stand up to the United States. Seizing Kuwait, as best we understand it, was part of that plan.
甚至在入侵科威特之前，萨达姆就已经说：“苏联的消亡使得世界失去了平衡。伊拉克必须成为新的超级大国，才能对抗美国。”夺取科威特，据我们所知，是该计划的一部分。
And we know this through his speeches, through--
我们通过他的演讲知道了这一点，通过——
Through his speeches, through Iraqis who've come out of Iraq, through even sources inside of Iraq who've all reported on this.
通过他的演讲，通过从伊拉克出来的伊拉克人，甚至通过伊拉克内部的消息来源，他们都报道了这一点。
In your view, did deterrents work when the United States warned him against using chemical or biological weapons during the Persian Gulf War, and then it turned out that he didn't?
在你看来，当美国警告他不要在波斯湾战争期间使用化学或生物武器，而后来发现他没用时，威慑起作用了吗？
We really don't know. And it's important to remember that James Baker, the Secretary of State, went to Saddam with three deterrent threats, which were, don't use weapons of mass destruction, don't conduct terrorist attacks, and don't light the Kuwaiti oil fields on fire. And if you do, we will do bad things to you. And it was unspecified consequences, very severe consequences. And it was the same statement for all three of those threats. Well, Saddam did light the Kuwaiti oil fields on fire. And he did engage in terrorist attacks and tried to attack the United States homeland.
我们真的不知道。重要的是要记住，国务卿詹姆斯·贝克带着三个威慑性威胁去找萨达姆，分别是：不要使用大规模杀伤性武器，不要进行恐怖袭击，不要点燃科威特的油田。如果你这样做，我们将对你做坏事。这是未具体说明的后果，非常严重的后果。这三个威胁的声明是一样的。嗯，萨达姆确实点燃了科威特的油田。他确实参与了恐怖袭击，并试图攻击美国本土。
Wait. What are the terrorist attacks you're talking about?
等等。你说的是什么恐怖袭击？
In 1991, during the Gulf War, Saddam launched a wave of terrorist attacks against the United States. They all failed.
1991年，波斯湾战争期间，萨达姆发动了一波针对美国的恐怖袭击。它们都失败了。
Now, we checked into this story, and it does seem to be true. There's a CIA counterterrorism guy out there who has written about it. Saddam did not heed our deterrent threats. He did launch attacks against the US during that war, which is exactly the point, Pollack says. Saddam will not be deterred.
现在，我们查了这个故事，它似乎是真的。有一个中情局的反恐人员写过这件事。萨达姆没有听从我们的威慑威胁。他确实在战争期间对美国发动了袭击，波拉克说，这正是重点。萨达姆是无法被威慑的。
Now, beyond that, one of the things that we learned after the Gulf War-- and, I think, was a very frightening thing for myself and many of my colleagues in the government to find out-- was that Saddam apparently concluded after the Gulf War that his biggest mistake during the Gulf War was not that he should never have invaded Kuwait, but that he should have waited to invade Kuwait, that he should have waited until he had a nuclear weapon. Because, he apparently believes, if he has a nuclear weapon, it is the United States that will be deterred, not him.
现在，除此之外，波斯湾战争后我们学到的——我认为对于我和政府中的许多同事来说是一件非常可怕的事情——是萨达姆在波斯湾战争后显然得出的结论是：他在波斯湾战争期间最大的错误不是他不应该入侵科威特，而是他应该等待再入侵科威特，他应该等到他拥有核武器。因为，他显然认为，如果他拥有核武器，受威慑的将是美国，而不是他。
Now, how do we know this? How do we know he thinks this?
那么，我们怎么知道呢？我们怎么知道他是这么想的？
We know it from a variety of different sources, including Iraqis who are close to Saddam, and also through a variety of technical means.
我们通过各种不同的渠道知道，包括接近萨达姆的伊拉克人，也通过各种技术手段。
Technical means, means listening in, spying in various ways?
技术手段，意味着监听、以各种方式刺探？
Exactly.
完全正确。
I'm guessing this must be how it goes when you talk to any former CIA guy. He tells you incredible things that explain so much about what your government is thinking and where policies come from, and then, as soon as you ask for details or evidence, he can't tell you. They're secret. Kenneth Pollack was able to explain, though, why so many US policymakers fear Saddam could not be deterred from using a nuclear bomb, if he ever got one, in a way that made it very, very clear. He says, imagine Saddam Hussein decided to threaten the country of Jordan.
我猜，当你和任何前中情局人员交谈时，情况就是这样。他告诉你一些令人难以置信的事情，解释了为什么你的政府在思考这些，以及政策来自哪里，然后，一旦你要求细节或证据，他就不能告诉你了。那是机密。不过，肯尼斯·波拉克能够解释为什么如此多的美国决策者担心萨达姆无法被威慑而不会使用核弹，他用一种非常、非常清晰的方式表达了出来。他说，想象萨达姆·侯赛因决定威胁约旦。
And what Saddam could conceivably threaten to do is, if you come and try to stop me from moving into Jordan, I will use nuclear weapons on regional targets. Israel, if you come after me, I will use them on Dimona. United States, if you come after me, I will use them against the Saudi oil fields. And then, the question becomes for the United States, do we want to dare Saddam?
萨达姆可以想象威胁要做的是：如果你来阻止我进入约旦，我将在地区目标上使用核武器。以色列，如果你来追捕我，我将在迪莫纳使用它们。美国，如果你来追捕我，我将对沙特油田使用它们。然后，问题对美国来说就变成了：我们想敢于对抗萨达姆吗？
And why isn't Saddam in the same position, though, that the Soviet Union would be? If he were to use his nuclear weapon, he knows the United States would just come in and blow him up?
但是，萨达姆为什么不像苏联那样处于同一个位置呢？如果他要使用核武器，他知道美国会直接进去并炸毁他？
Well, again, this is the problem with Saddam's thinking. As best we understand it, he is not making the same calculation that the Soviets did.
嗯，再说一次，这就是萨达姆思维的问题。据我们所知，他并没有做出与苏联相同的计算。
And just so I understand the logic that would be behind what Saddam is thinking, his thinking is the United States would be faced with this choice: Are we going to drop a bomb on Baghdad and kill hundreds of thousands of people? And the United States, when faced with that choice, would blink. We wouldn't want to do that?
为了理解萨达姆想法背后的逻辑，他的想法是美国将面临这样的选择：我们要向巴格达投下一枚炸弹，杀死成千上万的人吗？而美国在面临那个选择时，会退缩吗？我们不想这样做？
Correct. Again, that is our understanding of Saddam's thinking.
正确。再说一次，这就是我们对萨达姆思维的理解。
I have to say, in a way, I feel like I understand that. It is hard to imagine the United States dropping a nuclear bomb on a city right now.
我不得不说，在某种程度上，我觉得我理解这一点。很难想象美国现在会向一个城市投下核弹。
Imagine a scenario where Saddam is basically saying, if you stop me from going into Jordan, or Kuwait, or wherever the country may be, I'm going to blow up the Saudi oil fields. And your only response is to nuke the city of Baghdad, with 5 million innocent people. Let me put it this way. As a former US policymaker, that is not the kind of choice that I ever want to be in.
想象一下萨达姆基本上在说：如果你阻止我进入约旦、科威特或任何国家，我就要炸毁沙特油田。而你们唯一的反应是核平巴格达这座有500万无辜人民的城市。让我这样说吧。作为一名前美国决策者，那不是我永远不想面临的那种选择。
So where are you and I supposed come down on this? What should we believe? Could Saddam Hussein be deterred from using a nuclear weapon or not? Or maybe that's not even the right question in the end.
那么，你和我应该在这个问题上得出什么结论？我们应该相信什么？萨达姆·侯赛因能不能被威慑而不会使用核武器？或者最后，那甚至不是正确的问题。
You know, it's not really about keeping Saddam from getting nuclear capacity. That's not the central reason for doing this, I think. Or it's a reason, but not the only reason.
你知道，这并不是为了防止萨达姆获得核能力。我认为，这不是做这件事的核心原因。或者这是一个原因，但不是唯一的原因。
Again, Nicholas Lemann, from The New Yorker.
再说一次，尼古拉斯·莱曼，来自《纽约客》。
I think there's a sense in the conservative world that the nuclear threat is the argument most likely to sell with the public, but isn't the only reason to do this.
我认为在保守派世界中，有一种感觉认为核威胁是最容易向公众兜售的论点，但并不是做这件事的唯一原因。
The other reasons to do this, Lemann says, are right there if you talk to the Hawks, or if you read what they wrote before they took office. First, it's doable. We're going after Saddam Hussein not because he's so strong, but, in essence, because he's so weak. The Hawks see him as easy to defeat, compared with say, North Korea. And they believe that they can change the political climate in the Middle East through a show of force.
莱曼说，做这件事的其他原因，如果你和鹰派谈话，或者如果你读过他们在上任前写的东西，就会发现。首先，它是可行的。我们对付萨达姆·侯赛因不是因为他太强大，而是本质上因为他太虚弱。鹰派认为他很容易被击败，比如与朝鲜相比。他们相信可以通过武力展示来改变中东的政治气候。
People in the administration are fond of quoting Bernard Lewis, the eminent historian, who has been down and briefed people at the White House and so on. And they will quote him saying, Arab culture, in particular, respects strength and shows of force. It's a warrior culture. So if you invade a country like Iraq and win, rather than that inflaming the Middle East, it will quiet the Middle East, because people will respect you more.
政府里的人喜欢引用伯纳德·刘易斯的观点，他是杰出的历史学家，曾去白宫向人们做过简报等等。他们会引用他的话说，阿拉伯文化尤其尊重力量和武力展示。这是一种武士文化。所以如果你入侵像伊拉克这样的国家并获胜，那不仅不会激怒中东，反而会使中东平静下来，因为人们会更尊重你。
This, in a way, was the most surprising scenario I heard from anyone, Lemann's summary of how the Hawks imagine all of this could work in the end.
在某种程度上，这是我从任何人那里听到的最令人惊讶的场景，莱曼关于鹰派如何想象所有这一切最终如何奏效的总结。
Well, I think this is the scenario. First thing that happens is, we would set up some kind of permanent or semi-permanent military base or presence in Iraq. We could get rid of the Prince Sultan Air Force Base in Saudi Arabia and make Iraq the United States' military base of operations. It's a nice central location in the Middle East. Second of all, having a friendly government there and having a steady supply of oil from the Iraqi oil fields would make us much less dependent on Saudi oil. And that's a good thing, because then you get more leverage with the Saudis.
好吧，我认为这就是场景。首先发生的事情是，我们将建立某种永久或半永久性的军事基地或在伊拉克的存在。我们可以摆脱沙特阿拉伯的苏尔坦亲王空军基地，使伊拉克成为美国的军事行动基地。这是中东一个不错的中枢位置。其次，在那里建立一个友好的政府，并从伊拉克油田获得稳定的石油供应，将使我们减少对沙特石油的依赖。这很好，因为那样你对沙特人就有更多的筹码。
So here's some of the ways it would play out, according to the Hawks. First of all, the government of Iran would fall to some of these kind of student protest groups or other reform groups.
根据鹰派的说法，情况会按照以下方式发展。首先，伊朗政府会倒台，被某些学生抗议团体或其他改革团体所取代。
Because the student groups would see, oh, look, there's been change in Iraq. We want a more secular society, more modern society.
因为学生团体看到，噢，看，伊拉克发生了变化。我们想要一个更世俗的社会，更现代的社会。
Yes. And they'd be getting heavy encouragement and funding from the United States. Syria is another country where the Hawks very clearly want to see the government fall, and believe that it may well fall in the wake of a successful US invasion of Iraq.
是的。而且他们会得到美国的大力鼓励和资助。叙利亚是另一个国家，鹰派非常清楚地希望看到政府倒台，并相信它很可能在美国成功入侵伊拉克后倒台。
Then, I think, what they'd like to have happen is the two really big countries in the Middle East that are our friends, Saudi Arabia and Egypt, we could go to them and have very serious and soulful conversations with the governments, in which we say, we want a little better behavior out of you guys. We want you to really crack down on the Islamists. We don't want any more movies of protocols of the Elders of Zion on Egyptian television. We want you to move toward allowing opposition parties, including secular parties. Just kind of put the lid on the tide of Islamist extremism in your country. And if you don't, expect there to be negative consequences that will be short of military invasion, but painful to you from us, the United States.
然后，我认为，他们希望看到的是中东两个我们真正的大国朋友，沙特阿拉伯和埃及，我们可以去找他们，进行非常严肃和深情的对话，对他们说：“我们希望你们表现得好一点。我们希望你们真正打击伊斯兰极端分子。我们不希望在埃及电视上再看到关于《锡安长老会纪要》的电影。我们希望你们向允许反对党，包括世俗政党迈进。只是把国内伊斯兰极端主义的潮水盖上盖子。如果你们不这样做，预期会有消极后果，虽然达不到军事入侵的程度，但对你们来说是痛苦的，来自我们，美国。”
I feel like everything you're saying, at some point or another during the last six months, I've read in a kind of shorthand. And I feel like this is the first time I'm hearing somebody lay the whole thing out: This is why we're going to war.
我觉得你在说的每一件事，在过去六个月的某个时候，我都以一种速记的方式读到过。我觉得这是我第一次听到有人把整件事都铺陈出来：这就是我们为什么要开战。
I think this is why we're going to war, yes. I do think so. I mean, I think we are going to war. And I don't think it's not about weapons of mass destruction and the idea that Saddam might acquire nuclear weapons. And I don't think it's irrelevant that he's a brutal, totalitarian dictator who has murdered his own people. But I really think the primary goal here is to try to use this as an opening into a remaking of the Middle East.
我想这就是我们开战的原因，是的。我是这么认为的。我的意思是，我认为我们正在开战。我不认为这与大规模杀伤性武器以及萨达姆可能获得核武器的想法无关。我也不认为他是一个残酷的、集权独裁者，杀害了自己的人民，这一点无关紧要。但我真的认为这里的主要目标是试图将其作为重塑中东的开端。
Nicholas Lemann. You can read his article about all this called, "The War on What?" online at The New Yorker magazine website. [MUSIC-"READY TO DIE" BY ANDREW W.K.]
尼古拉斯·莱曼。你可以在《纽约客》杂志网站上在线阅读他关于这一切的文章，题为《对什么进行战争？》。[音乐-安德鲁·W.K.的《准备赴死》]
Act Five, Who Cares? Well, it's been a heady hour of radio. And we have to admit, it's Christmas. While we all may have nagging fears about the War against terror, or the war against Iraq, or the war against whatever, we all have a lot of other things on our minds. And if you have any doubt about that at all, all you have to do is look at this new website started by this guy named Gabe Hudson.
第五幕，谁在乎？嗯，这是一个令人振奋的广播小时。我们必须承认，这是圣诞节。虽然我们对反恐战争、或对伊战争、或对任何战争都可能有挥之不去的恐惧，但我们所有人脑子里还有很多其他事情。如果你对此有任何疑问，你所要做的就是看看这个由盖比·哈德森的人创办的新网站。
He was a rifleman in the Marine Reserves in 1992, just as the Gulf War was ending. And he wrote this book of short stories called Dear Mr. President . And partly as a crude promotion, and partly as an idealistic public-minded venture, he started a website where he invited everyday Americans to post their own letters to the President. Well, one of the letters was posted there by a teacher in North Carolina and her class. Out of 19 kids, note that only five had anything to say about the War on Terror.
1992年波斯湾战争即将结束时，他是海军预备役的一名步枪手。他写了一本短篇小说集叫《亲爱的总统先生》。部分是为了粗鲁的推销，部分是为了理想主义的公众心态，他创办了一个网站，邀请普通美国人发布他们写给总统的信。嗯，其中一封信是由北卡罗来纳州的一位老师和她的班级发布的。在19个孩子中，只有5个对反恐战争有话要说。
"Dear Mr. President, Hello there. I live in a small town in North Carolina. Well, that's not exactly right. I live outside a small town, what may be termed rural. I live deep down a dirt road in a wooden house beside a creek that's cut into orange clay. This is where I grew up. It's nice here.
“亲爱的总统先生，你好。我住在北卡罗来纳州的一个小镇。嗯，那不太准确。我住在小镇外，可以被称为乡村的地方。我住在一条土路的深处，溪边的一栋木屋里，溪水切入了橙色的粘土。这是我长大的地方。这里很好。
I teach English here, eighth grade. Most eighth graders have a lot of opinions. Some of them don't. I asked them all to write down something that they would like to say to you. And I thought you might be interested in hearing their responses.
我在这里教英语，八年级。大多数八年级学生有很多意见。他们中的一些没有。我要求他们每个人写下他们想对你说的话。我想你可能有兴趣听听他们的回答。
I'm very glad that we have a good Christian man as our president.
我很高兴我们有一位好的基督徒担任我们的总统。
Whitney Moore, who is the shortest person in her class.
惠特尼·摩尔，班上最矮的人。
You need to get out of the office and really need to be replaced.
你需要离开办公室，真的需要被替换。
Reyna Pacheco, who admires Selena.
雷娜·帕切科，崇拜赛琳娜。
Mr. Bush, I would rather you use another country to handle your wars and light work, because I want Osama to feel like he's going up against a gang, and not just one person.
布什先生，我宁愿你用另一个国家来处理你的战争和轻工作，因为我想让奥萨马觉得他在对抗一个帮派，而不是一个人。
Will Castillo, who will be a famous writer one day.
威尔·卡斯蒂略，有一天会成为著名的作家。
My favorite president is you, Mr. Bush.
我最喜欢的总统是你，布什先生。
Jonathan King, who makes odd noises in class.
乔纳森·金，在课堂上制造奇怪的噪音。
Do you think we'll ever find bin Laden? And when we do, will things go back to normal?
你认为我们能找到本·拉登吗？当我们找到他时，事情会恢复正常吗？
Melissa Jackson, cheerleader.
梅丽莎·杰克逊，啦啦队长。
I want to know, why is the writing test so important to North Carolina schools? And why should it determine if we fail or pass a grade, or if we have met the standards of the writing test? And why is it the end-of-grade test is so important?
我想知道，为什么写作考试对北卡罗来纳州的学校如此重要？为什么它应该决定我们是挂科还是通过，或者我们是否达到了写作考试的标准？为什么期末考试如此重要？
Nikki Norman, who resembles Alicia Keys.
尼基·诺曼，长得像艾丽西亚·凯斯。
Why would you be president, knowing that many people don't like you? The war didn't happen until you became President of the United States of America.
为什么你会想当总统，明知很多人不喜欢你？战争直到你成为美利坚合众国总统才发生。
Tarika Williams, who is serious.
塔丽卡·威廉姆斯，很严肃。
What would you do to make the world a better place?
你会做什么让世界变得更美好？
Leticia Antonio, who has impeccable handwriting.
莱蒂西亚·安东尼奥，笔迹完美。
Bush, I think you're doing an excellent job considering the terrorist attacks and the sniper attacks, and even the fights between Elizabeth Dole and Erskine Bowles.
布什，考虑到恐怖袭击和狙击手袭击，甚至伊丽莎白·多尔和厄斯金·鲍尔斯之间的争斗，我认为你做得很好。
Natalie Calcutt, who hangs out on the back hall.
娜塔莉·卡尔库特，在后厅晃荡。
How many four-wheelers, et cetera, do you have? And how many food restaurants do you have in your house?
你有多少辆四轮摩托车等等？你家有多少个食品餐馆？
Tara Spell, who plays three sports.
塔拉·斯佩尔，玩三种运动。
Did you ever think when you were little that one day you would be president?
你小时候想过有一天你会当总统吗？
Madelyn Wooten, who also hangs out on the back hall.
马德琳·伍顿，也在后厅晃荡。
I think they should have more church camps. I love going to them.
我认为他们应该有更多的教会营地。我喜欢去那些地方。
Karen Cribb, who has a big smile.
凯伦·克里布，笑容灿烂。
My name Michelle Blue. And I am wondering, what are you going to do about the elderly people without Social Security, and they're not able to work, and they've got to be the age of 65 to be able to stop working?
我叫米歇尔·布鲁。我想知道，你打算怎么处理那些没有社会保障的老年人，他们不能工作，却必须到65岁才能停止工作？
Michelle Blue, who speaks in one long sentence as well.
米歇尔·布鲁，说话也是一个长句子。
I like cats.
我喜欢猫。
Courtney Barefoot, who also likes boys.
考特尼·赤脚，也喜欢男孩。
Try to stop the war so we wouldn't have to worry about it anymore.
试着停止战争，这样我们就不用再担心它了。
Jose Jose, real name.
何塞·何塞，真名。
Why do terrorists want to kill you so much?
为什么恐怖分子那么想杀你？
April Tew, who flirts.
艾普丽尔·特，很会调情。
I'm 13 years old and in the eighth grade. I go to Midway Middle. I like to talk on the phone to boys and play soccer. My favorite subject is math, but my favorite teacher is my language arts teacher, Miss Honeycutt.
我13岁，上八年级。我去中途中学。我喜欢和男孩打电话，踢足球。我最喜欢的科目是数学，但我最喜欢的老师是我的语言艺术老师，霍尼卡特小姐。
Leslie Strickland, who sucks up.
莱斯利·斯特里克兰，很会拍马屁。
My birthday is November 12. And I will be 15. So if you are a president, you will get me something.
我的生日是11月12日。我将满15岁。所以如果你是总统，你会送我东西。
James Brady, who raps.
詹姆斯·布雷迪，会说唱。
I just want to say that you need to take your job more seriously.
我只想说你需要更认真地对待你的工作。
Teresa Goodman, who can do a mean Harlem Shake.
特蕾莎·古德曼，会跳地道的哈莱姆摇摆舞。
These are my kids. They just wanted you to know that they are here. Sincerely, Britt Honeycutt."
这些是我的孩子。他们只是想让你知道他们在这里。诚挚地，布里特·霍尼卡特。”
If you want to write to the President as part of this project, go to gabehudson.com. Otherwise, you know, there's always that 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue address you can use.
如果你想作为这个项目的一部分给总统写信，去gabehudson.com。否则，你知道，总有那个宾夕法尼亚大道1600号的地址你可以用。
I mean, I find it very confusing myself. I think there are a few-- George Bush-- it's very hard to fight.
我是说，我觉得这非常令人困惑。我觉得有一些——乔治·布什——这很难对抗。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际公司。